We have been given the scientific knowledge
the technical ability and the materials to
pursue the exploration of the universe, to
ignore this great resources would be a corruption
of a god given ability.
It’s estimated that about 650 million people
watched the first moon landing in 1969 - nearly
a quarter of the world’s population.
As the world watched those powerful Saturn
V rocket engines burst into life, they witnessed
plumes of sooty exhaust billow from its 5
shuddering nozzles as it pushed itself off
the ground, burning through a colossal volume
of kerosene to lift the rocket’s massive
3 million kilogram weight off the ground.
Soon the first stage shut off and separated,
allowing the second stage to roar into life.
This time powered by a different fuel, liquid
hydrogen.
A fuel capable of providing better performance,
but it occupied too much space.
Liquid hydrogen is considerably less dense
than kerosene, so needs to be combined in
a much higher ratio with liquid oxygen.
For every litre of liquid oxygen burned in
the Saturn V first stage, it required 0.64
litres of kerosene, while its second stage
needed 3.25 litres of liquid hydrogen for
every litre of oxygen.
NASA engineers couldn’t feasibly make the
Saturn V first stage fuel tanks any larger,
so liquid hydrogen was not an option.
The science of rocket fuel is a fascinating
and complicated field.
Combining not just physics, chemistry, and
engineering, but also logistics.
That’s the challenge facing Space X as it
develops the next generation of heavy lift
rockets, designed to take us not just to the
Moon, but further, to Mars.
Starship’s Raptor engines will not use kerosene
or liquid hydrogen.
It will use methane.
A fuel that was considered frequently over
the past century of rocket fuel research,
with a few honourable mentions in John D Clarks’
seminal book, “Ignition!”, but it has
never seen widespread use.
So, why is SpaceX using it now?
Putting people on the moon in the 1960s was
one of the greatest technological challenges
we’d ever faced, but getting humans to Mars
is a considerably more difficult task, especially
when you factor in the enormous challenge
of keeping humans there - of creating and
sustaining a human settlement on the red planet.
How do you reduce the cost of launches?
How do you make the oxygen needed to stay
alive, how do you provide water for growing
food and for drinking, and how do you make
the fuel to power a return trip to Earth?
Kerosene and Hydrogen are not perfect.
Kerosene is extracted from crude oil via fractional
distillation and is made up of a mixture of
long-chain hydrocarbons, reaching up to around
20 carbons in length.
The longer the hydrocarbon, the harder it
is for it to burn completely in oxygen, as
they require more oxygen per gram of fuel
to be completely oxidised into carbon dioxide
and water.
And so, even in its refined form, kerosene
often burns incompletely, decomposing instead
into smaller, reactive radicals.
The result is coking - the production of sooty
carbon particulates that we saw in the Saturn
Vs launch.
This soot can easily clog up the intricate
mechanism of a rocket engine, which is a problem
for SpaceX and its goal to make its engines
reusable with minimal maintenance.
Especially on Mars, where the facilities to
fix these issues will not be available.
Liquid hydrogen, of course, doesn’t have
this problem, and it has the advantage of
burning more efficiently than kerosene.
We can quantify this efficiency with specific
impulse.
Specific impulse describes how efficiently
a fuel can convert its mass into thrust.
To understand this let’s first look at total
impulse, which describes the thrust force
generated over the entire burn period of the
engine.
We can graph this rather easily, by plotting
the thrust the engine is providing in each
second of its flight, that may look something
like this.
The total impulse is found by finding the
area under this graph, which gives us the
total energy the rocket released.
This is a useful metric in itself, but specific
impulse is better, because not all propellants
are born equal.
Two different fuel and oxidiser combinations
could provide the same total impulse, but
we need to consider the weight of the fuel
and oxidisers themselves, after all, the initial
weight of rockets is always dominated by the
weight of their own fuel.
To find the average specific impulse we divide
the total impulse by total propellant weight
the rocket expelled.
[4]
Going by this metric, a liquid hydrogen and
liquid oxygen fuel mixture is by far the best.
(Table from [1])
Hydrogen has a much higher specific impulse
than kerosene [1] - around 390 seconds, against
kerosenes’s 285 seconds.
However, as mentioned earlier, Hydrogen is
much less dense than kerosene.
Requiring much larger fuel tanks.
Hydrogen also has an exceptionally low boiling
point at minus 252.8 degrees celsius - and
so the tanks need to be heavily insulated
to avoid expansion of the liquid hydrogen,
but thermodynamic equilibrium is a war of
attrition that will the universe will always
win, and so it also requires boil off valves
to release gaseous hydrogen to prevent an
explosion.
This all adds mass and complexity to the rocket.
Hydrogen also degrades and weakens metals
in a process known as hydrogen embrittlement.
This is a massive issue for SpaceX’s reusability
design ethos.
Combining two parameters, the density and
the specific heat of combustion, we can get
an idea of the difference between these 3
fuels.
If we want to release 100 Megajoules of energy
from each of these three fuels, we would need
11.9 liters of hydrogen, 2.2 liters of kerosene,
or 5.5 liters of methane.
Methane is much closer to kerosene than hydrogen.
Allowing fuel tanks to be smaller than liquid
hydrogen fuel tanks, but not small enough
to offer much performance benefits over kerosene.
When the necessary design changes are made
to switch from kerosene to liquid methane,
like increasing the fuel tank volume, the
increase in specific impulse is all but negated.
This is why Methane hasn’t seen use yet.
Methane simply sits in an awkward middle ground
between the two most popular fuels.
It provides better performance than kerosene,
but not as good as hydrogen.
And it’s easier to store than hydrogen,
but not as easy as kerosene.
Its benefits are only now becoming useful
as SpaceX works to unlock the magic of reusable
rockets.[2].
Methane is a single-carbon hydrocarbon, so
unlike the long-chain molecules found in kerosene,
it produces significantly less soot when burnt,
leading to less damage to the engine over
time.
Its boiling point is actually higher than
liquid oxygens.
Allowing much of the necessary infrastructure
to liquify and use oxygen to be also used
for liquid methane.
Important when working with limited infrastructure
on Mars.
But, most importantly, the real reason methane
has suddenly become very attractive to SpaceX
is that it can be synthesised from the carbon
dioxide rich atmosphere of Mars.
Mars’ atmosphere is almost entirely carbon
dioxide.
95% of the Martian atmosphere is CO2, with
the remaining 5% being made up from gases
like nitrogen, argon and a trace amount of
oxygen.
Whilst this carbon dioxide-rich atmosphere
may be a disadvantage when it comes to establishing
a city on Mars, it provides huge advantages
when it comes to creating rocket fuel.
We have come to see carbon dioxide as a waste
gas - something produced as a by-product of
combustion, instead of as a raw material,
but it has the enormous potential to act as
a feedstock for the production of methane.
Over 100 years ago, a chemist called Paul
Sabatier came up with a process of converting
carbon dioxide into methane by passing it
through a catalyst, usually Nickel, with hydrogen
gas at an elevated temperature and pressure.
The reaction takes one mole of carbon dioxide
and reacts it with four moles of hydrogen
to produce one mole of methane and two of
water.
When combined with our electrolysis process,
this produces one mole of methane to two moles
of oxygen.
The ratio of moles - the stoichiometry - is
going to be important soon.
But the first question is, how do you get
your chemical reagents on Mars?
Well for this, we need In Situ Resource Utilisation.
Getting carbon dioxide is a relatively easy
task.
With an atmosphere made up from 95% CO2, extracting
a pure sample of the compound is straightforward
enough, but we do need to get rid of that
other 5% and condense the carbon dioxide.
Currently, cryofreezing is the most viable
option, carbon dioxide has the highest freezing
point of the gases present in Mars’ atmosphere.
So, in a process that is essentially the opposite
of distillation, we can cool the air to separate
the carbon dioxide, which will freeze into
a solid while the other gases remain as gas.
This also naturally compresses the gas.
Then, when we need to use it in our sabatier
reactor it can be simply warmed up to create
a high pressure stream of gaseous CO2. [3].
However, getting the necessary hydrogen is
much more difficult.
The first option is to import it directly
from Earth, but given how much is required,
and the difficulty storing it for long periods,
this isn’t a great option.
So, long term, we will want to extract it
from resources available on Mars.
Water is contained within Martian soil, but,
most significantly, it’s found in the form
of ice in the polar regions of the planet.
If we can find an efficient way of mining
the water, we can then convert it into oxygen
and hydrogen using an electric current, and
then the hydrogen can be combined with carbon
dioxide to produce methane.
Remember when we said the molar ratios would
be important.
Here’s why.
That 2:1 molar ratio of oxygen to methane,
gives us a mass ratio of 4:1 of oxygen to
methane.
The propellant mixture employed by SpaceX’s
raptor engine uses a 3.4 : 1 ratio, so this
whole process gives us an excess of oxygen,
which can be put towards the life support
systems in your Martian city [3].
A win win.
But extracting large quantities of water from
Mars, either from ice in the polar regions
or from the small quantities of liquid water
in the soil, would not be easy, and the technology
to do this on a large scale doesn’t exist
yet.
Over the short term, if we brought our own
hydrogen to Mars, we end up with a 1:1 mole
ratio of oxygen and methane, which isn’t
enough to burn our methane completely.
So, if we are going this route, we need a
way to produce additional oxygen.
The best way is to use another process which
would benefit from Mars’ carbon dioxide
rich atmosphere - the Reverse Water Gas Shift
reaction (RWGS).
This looks very similar to the Sabatier process,
and involves the reaction of carbon dioxide
with hydrogen, but instead of producing methane
and water, it produces carbon monoxide and
water.
The water that’s formed in this reaction
can then be electrolysed, and the hydrogen
recycled back into the reactor
Again, when the equations of the processes
are combined, it gives us the 2 : 1 molar
ratio between oxygen and methane that’s
needed for the propellant mixture.
This gives us options if mining water on Mars
proves difficult.
But the additional advantage of this approach
is that these two reactions - Sabatier and
Reverse Water Gas Shift - can be done in the
same reactor, as demonstrated by Pioneer Astronautics
in 2005 [3].
This combination of these two reactions has
an enormous thermal advantage.
Because the Sabatier reaction is exothermic
- it releases heat energy - and the Reverse
Water Gas Shift reaction is endothermic - it
absorbs heat - it leads to an overall reduction
of 37% in heat generation, improving the efficiency
of the whole process [3].
But despite how long the Sabatier reaction
has been around, the research into optimising
the process is only a couple of decades old.
For most of its life, the Sabatier reaction
has been used to remove carbon dioxide from
hydrogen in the production of ammonia, as
it damages the catalysts used in the process
of making ammonia, but in the last twenty
years, scientists have begun to realise its
potential in helping mitigate the effects
of climate change.
Instead of letting the carbon dioxide formed
from burning fossil fuels into the atmosphere,
what if we could collect it, and turn it back
into fuel using the Sabatier process [7]?
This would require a method of not only efficiently
capturing carbon dioxide from the air, but
a method of creating hydrogen.
These processes are currently expensive, but
work is being done to reduce the cost in both
energy and money.
This could create a realistic economy for
carbon capture to help mitigate climate change,
but we are a long way off from it being cheap
enough.
If the technology advances, it could offer
a method of storing renewable energy over
extremely long periods of time as methane.
There are already a handful of Power to Gas
plants and projects in operation, like the
Audi e-gas plant in Germany [3], but it has
not yet reached wide-scale use.
In December of last year, Elon Musk tweeted
that SpaceX is funding programmes into carbon
capture and storage, adding that the research
would also be important for SpaceX’s Mars
missions.
It’s not yet clear exactly what they are
developing, but it will likely be very similar
to the Power to Gas projects already in development,
based on the century-old Sabatier reaction.
People often criticise NASA and other space
initiatives as a waste of time, why work on
scientific research to help us live in space
or on other planets when we have so many issues
that need research here on earth, but it’s
clear for anyone paying attention.
Working on difficult problems to make Mars
habitable, will directly lead to helping solve
the greatest problem facing Earth today.
This problem needs all hands on deck.
We need as many talented engineers and scientists
working on climate change as possible.
That’s part of the mission of this channel,
to inspire the next generation of engineers,
which is why I work with Brilliant.
Where I can inspire, Brilliant can educate.
Brilliant has created the perfect learning
platform for science and mathematics.
Focusing on interactivity that helps you truly
understand complicated subjects, and continually
tests your knowledge as you go along.
If you are stuck on a particular question,
Brilliant does not punish you and impede your
progress, instead they give you an in depth
explanation to guide you on your learning
path.
Encouraging you to learn from your mistakes,
rather than building a barrier to further
learning.
You can start your learning journey on any
number of courses, from neutral networks and
algorithms to logic and probability.
You can learn at your own pace, learn on the
go with their mobile app, and most importantly
of all enjoy the process.
You can try Brilliant for free with the link
in the comments and description or by clicking
the button on screen now, and the first 200
people to sign up will get 20% off Brilliant
Premium.
If you are looking for something else to watch
right now you could watch our last video on
the insane engineering of the javelin missile,
or you could watch Real Science’s recent
video on the insane biology of the Harpy Eagle.